and social impact business or
social business or social business are
market strategies companies that
combine social impact with
profit generation in general are companies whose
first and most important intention is
to generate impact i.e. social impact
is linked to the core business of the company
and  these are companies that must intend
to achieve scale because the
social problems we are experiencing are quite
large. There is a large part of the
population that is not
adequately served by health services,
education, financial services, housing.
of solving problems that
are basic for the development of the
low-income population in Brazil
This is the measurement of social impact
it is A Challenge not only in the field of
impact businesses but also in the
third sector in non-
profit organizations in this case  of
impact investing and impact business the
methodology most adopted today and most
known  ecida is Gears is is a king has a
rating system so is Global Impact
investing in great britain System The
advantage of this methodology is that it is a
Global methodology adopted by a number
of players in the field of
impact investing and which then allows you to
compare the performance of different
businesses if on the one hand this is good on the
other hand it still has some
limitations
it does not fully adapt to all
contexts it needs to be
adapted so that it works well in
different emerging markets But it is a
very open methodology  to move
Improvements and have received a lot of feedback
from those who are using it
is probably a methodology that will
develop far beyond this
methodology some businesses or some
Funds and accelerators are
developing their own
methodologies but I think the big
challenge today is us  find a
methodology that is cheap, low
cost and quick to implement for
entrepreneurs who  who are still in the
early stage of their business